-In the notes, you thanked
the New York City subway.
I have never in my time here
heard anyone say,
"Thank you, subway."
[ Laughter ]
So what was it
about the New York City subway
that you felt in debt to?
-Well, I mean --
Okay, and here's --
I feel like I need
to disclaim by --
You know, I understand if you've
lived here for a long time,
and you've caught the subway
5,000 times, you would hate it.
-Yeah.
-For me, it still has
a bit of romance.
Even though I did get
stuck on it for four hours.
-Oh, you were on the train
that got stuck for four hours?
-Yes, I was.
-That sounded really awful.
-Sitting on the floor
for four hours.
-Wow! And when you're sitting
on the floor for four hours,
does anyone notice
that Lorde is on the train?
-I don't know if they noticed.
All I could think about
was that I had
a little oatmeal sachet
in my bag, and I was like,
if anyone finds out,
this is gonna be,
like, prized commodity.
[ Laughter ]
Like, it's gonna be like "Lost."
This will be my family now.
-Yeah.
-We're gonna be here forever.
-'Cause, see,
I would've immediately thought,
"Oh, what can I barter
with my oatmeal?"
Like, "What can I
get off people?"
-What can you
barter down there, though?
Like, more food?
-I would just, like,
raise the price.
I would be like, "This usually
is a dollar, but now it's $150."
-You sit on the floor,
give me your seat."
-Exactly.
-No, but I love the subway.
I feel like it was really nice
riding this.
I would kind of sit there
and listen to the work,
and it helped me kind of
be around people,
you know, 'cause when
you're working in a studio,
you're very isolated
and kind of just hang out
with a couple of people.
So I feel like it sort of
reintroduced me
back into society.
And people would be very sweet.
They'd kind of --
You know,
someone would be like...
and sort of do a little look,
and I'd be like, "Shh, shh."
[ Laughter ]
-So, I was reading an article
where you were talking --
And has this
been your whole life, this --
the way you see colors?
-Oh, yes.
[ Laughs ]
-Well, I guess --
What is it?
It's not that you hear --
Explain it for me.
-Okay.
So, it's called synesthesia,
and, basically, it's like when
the senses overlap in some way.
So, for me, music and words
kind of have colors
and textures and forms.
And it's like
this weird, abstract thing,
but making music is, like,
a really visual process for me.
-And so, then, is that how --
Do you describe
your music in colors?
Like, if you were
talking to Jack,
do you say, like,
"This is a little too..."
-Yeah, I try hard to keep
the color things away from,
like, synesthesia muggles
'cause they feel, like,
it's super-annoying,
but I would definitely like --
I would kind of --
[ Both laugh ]
I would slip and be, like...
"It just doesn't
look very nice,"
and he would be like,
"What do you want me
to do with that information?"
Like, "I can't --
There's nothing there."
-What would you say
are the colors of this album?
-Oh, well. They, uh --
They are the colors of the --
A lot of the color's in the
actual cover painting itself,
so it's violets and blues.
-The cover is beautiful.
And after I read that, I sort of
looked at the album art
and having listened
to some of the songs,
I had a real understanding.
Again, and I'm a muggle,
I'll admit, but...
[ Laughter ]
It did make total sense to me.
So I will say,
you really nailed it,
if those were the colors
you were looking for.
-Thank you.
-And I'm just so happy
to have you here,
and thank you so much for
singing a song off the album.
We can't wait.
-Thank you.
What a pleasure for me.
-Give it up for Lorde,
everybody.